>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Monica Enqvist: And
now to the important part,
introducing Jenny Rogneby,
the new queen Nordic Noir.
Swedish fiction is among the
most translated in the world.
Crime writers such as Stieg
Larsson, Camilla Lackberg
and Henning Mankell has helped --
have helped attract
international readers.
And now Jenny Rogneby
is helping us too.
Her book, Leona, The Dye is
Cast, was a best seller in Sweden
and has been sold to
13 different countries.
And it has already been sold to
Hollywood with the film rights.
And what is interesting
with Jenny is
that she really knows
what she's writing about.
She has a degree in Criminology
and has worked professionally
as a criminal investigator
in the Stockholm City Police
Department for seven years.
Inspired by her work, she moved
to Malta and started writing
and formed the character of Leona,
a criminal investigator whose
actions challenged social norms.
A crime gripping novel about one
woman's wish to shed her past
through any means possible, and
I really mean any means possible.
And I have just finished
the book myself
and it was really hard
to take a break.
I just wanted to continue
reading it, and especially
because Leona is immediately put
on the case of 7-year-old girl
who robs a bank without
saying a word.
This is a book with a lot of
unexpected twists, and that suggests
that we really never know
who we are working with
and what lies underneath
the surface.
And I will let you hear more
about the book and of course
about Jenny from herself.
And I just want to
mention one more thing.
I know that some of you might
already read the first book,
and I can tell you that she
already have written two more books
about Leona, but not yet
translated into English.
So with that, of course we
welcome to come to also Sweden
if you can't wait for
the translated version.
I promise to have the
Swedish lessons there.
So with that, please help me
and welcome Jenny, the
author behind Leona.
[ Applause ]
>> Jenny Rogneby: Thank you so
much for that great presentation.
I want to thank the
Washington Convention Center,
the National Book Festival
and the Library of Congress
for inviting me to
this marvelous event.
And I -- I also want to thank all
of you who came to see me today.
It's a great honor and
a privilege to be here.
When I arrived here yesterday,
someone asked me, where
are you from?
That might seem to be an
easy question to answer.
But for me, it's been harder
and harder to answer it.
I can't be sure what -- what
people mean when they ask me this.
Did the person mean
where I was born?
Or maybe where I lived
most part of my life?
Where I grew up?
Or maybe where I live now?
In my case, that is all
different places, so it depends.
Maybe the real question should
be, does it really matter?
But I know we all want to
understand and know more
and understand what's
in front of us.
So I'm going to tell you my story.
I will tell you a bit
about me and my journey
and what formed me as an author.
And I'll tell you about
my book, Serious Leona.
And I will tell -- also will
read a short part of the book.
Then I will be glad to answer
some if you have some questions.
Yes, so I'm Swedish.
I grew up in Sweden and I've
lived most of my life there.
I don't know how much
you know about Sweden.
Maybe you know the singing
group, ABBA or Volvo or IKEA.
Or maybe you know some of our most
famous authors, Stieg Larsson or --
and David Lagercrantz who
wrote the Millennium Series.
Or maybe you know Sweden because it
was the first country in the world
that banned physical
punishment for children.
Or maybe of our country's
hard work for gender equality.
But I wasn't born in Sweden.
I was born in Ethiopia,
and when I was 1-year-old,
I was given away for adoption.
By biological father passed
away soon after I was born
and my mother was left
with two children.
Times were hard there and she
wanted me to have a better life,
a better future than she
had and that you children
in Ethiopia had at that time.
I was put on a plane for
12 hours from Addis Abeba,
which is the capital of Ethiopia
with a stewardess checking
on me every now and then.
And I arrived to my
new parents in Sweden.
I grew in the north of Sweden,
in a small town called Boden.
By that time, Boden was
Sweden's largest military city.
And my both parents
worked in the Army.
Luckily I arrived in the
middle of the summer.
If you've ever been to Sweden in
the winter time, I think you know
and understand what I mean.
The summertime in -- in the
north of Sweden is beautiful
with the green forests, the
rivers and the midnight sun.
But when the winter came, it was
dark, I mean really, really dark.
The sun rises around
11 AM and sets at noon.
The only thing that lights up is
the snow, and there was a lot of it
and cold, minus 30 degrees Celsius.
That would be around minus 22
degrees Fahrenheit I believe.
That was nothing unusual
in the winter time.
And all the children
did winter sports.
We were skiing, skating,
snowboarding, you name it.
I wasn't dreaming about
being an author.
Actually, it wasn't even in my mind.
When I was a child, I wanted
to be a figure skater.
I saw them on television.
They were dancing and
they were doing pirouettes
on the -- on the ice.
And I -- I practiced outside
the river from where I lived
and there was really thick ice
there from October until May.
And I think I got really good at
it, but there was a big problem.
It was so cold.
I was freezing up there.
And I remember my mother
trying to keep me warm.
And I -- She rubbed her --
she rubbed my brown hands
in between her pale hands.
And she used to say to me that,
"Jenny, it's because you don't have
as thick blood as we have.
That's why you're so
cold all the time."
And she of course said
that with a lot of love.
But I was so cold.
Well, in the really
dark periods, I think --
I was thinking, I am not
made for this climate.
But actually who is made for that?
I mean that's a crazy way to live.
But my mother still lives there.
She loves it, so -- Anyway,
figure skating just wasn't for me.
But I was really different up there.
I looked different with my
dark skin and my afro hair.
And by that time, there
were almost no foreigners
at all in the north of Sweden.
As a child, you know, you
always want to fit in,
but for me, it was impossible.
But I think being different,
even though it wasn't easy,
it also made me -- it made
me -- I think I got --
I got the opportunity and I took
the chance to do different things
in life because I couldn't
fit in anyways, so I could --
I could go my own way
instead and I did.
So I didn't want to -- to go
my parent's path to the Army.
I wanted then to be a dancer since
I couldn't be a figure skater.
It was too cold.
So dancing was better.
It was indoors, so it was warm.
And so I moved from Boden to
Stockholm and educated myself
at the Ballet Academy and the
music school in Stockholm.
And I became a musical artist.
I worked as a singer and
dancer for many years.
And one day, I got a
phone call saying that --
that the band I was a singer
in got a really big gig.
We got the opportunity to be the
opening act for Michael Jackson.
Of course, I felt someone
was joking with me.
I mean, that's the phone call
that you don't get every day.
But it was true.
And after a few weeks,
I stand there --
I was standing there in
Estonia on a really --
I mean there was a biggest
stage I have ever seen
and an outdoors arena, performing
in front of nearly 80,000 people.
It was of course amazing.
But as you hear, there's nothing
about writing here
yet, but it's coming.
But I was now living in --
in Stockholm, which is a --
a lot bigger city than I grew up in.
And the thing is, I started to
notice when I was walking to the --
to the recording studio, I started
to notice the society around me.
I saw people on the streets having
all kinds of problems: drug addicts,
criminals, homeless people.
And I started to think about that.
I mean, I was born in one of the
world's most poorest countries,
and I grew up in one of the
world's richest countries.
So how come people were
living on the streets
and having all kinds of problems.
I wanted to know more about that.
So I started to study
at the university.
I started with Sociology,
which is the scientific study
about society and social
interaction.
And studied various
subjects within that field --
Psychology, Law, Social Work,
and I became very interested
in criminal behavior and crimes.
So I continued with that and
later became a criminologist.
And that's how I got
into the crime field.
For seven years, I worked
as a criminal investigator
at the Swedish Police
Department in Stockholm.
I investigated everything
from thefts,
robberies, to rapes and murders.
And now we're getting
a little bit closer.
Because all the hours I spent
on interrogating, questioning,
interviewing victims, witnesses and
-- and suspects, collecting evidence
and putting together police
investigations, that gave me a lot
of inspiration and
ideas for crime fiction.
I especially got an idea for
a certain character, Leona.
And that idea that
wouldn't leave me.
And I felt like I just
had to write it down.
So I thought to myself,
wouldn't it be really amazing
to have written a book in your life?
So that's why I did what I did.
But I knew it was a -- a big task.
To write a book, it's
really a lot of work.
And I wanted to give
it a fair chance.
I heard so many people say, "I want
-- going to write a book and I want
to do that," and maybe they
start, but they never finish.
So I took some time off from
work, actually one year.
And just to be able to
-- to write the book.
And during that time, a full
year, I didn't have a salary.
So I sold my apartment in Stockholm.
I sold all my furniture.
I just kept a few memories,
and then I moved abroad
because I didn't want
anything to distract me.
So I -- And okay -- I, to be
honest, I was a little bit tired
of the rainy Stockholm as well.
So, I wanted to be
somewhere where it was warm
and the climate was
better than Sweden.
So, I moved to Malta, you know,
the small little island just
below Sicily in the middle
of the Mediterranean Sea?
And there I sat -- The good thing
about Malta, it's sunny, it's --
I mean, I could walk on the --
on the boardwalk and think about
my characters and my story.
So -- And being there made me
notice all the details better
of the setting in Stockholm
where my book is -- is set.
So -- about the police work
and the rainy big city.
I sat there for one year
and I wrote this book there.
When I came back to
Sweden, I sent my script
to several publishing houses.
I -- I didn't know anything
about the book industry.
I had no contacts.
I didn't know a publisher or
anything like that, so I --
I checked from the -- on the
publishing house's websites how
to do when you're sending a script,
and I did it just like they wanted.
And then I waited.
It said that they wanted three
months to read and get back to you.
So I thought, okay I'll wait
probably summertime I will hear
from them, if I will hear from them.
But after only a week,
I got a phone call.
And I remember that day.
It was a quite busy day.
I was back at my work then at the
police force because, you know,
the free year that I
written the book was over,
so I had to start working again.
And that day was quite busy.
I was on my way to
interrogate a suspect,
and also there had been a --
a salesperson calling me at
least two times that day.
So, when my phone called
again, I thought it was him,
so I answered not very politely.
I was like, yes, like,
what do you want now?
And then he said he was
from a publishing company,
and I literally fell off my chair.
I had -- I had no idea they
were going to, you know,
call me and call me so quickly.
And after a few hours, another --
another publishing company emailed
me and also wanted to meet me.
I was really shocked.
And I -- It continued like that
until ten Swedish publishing houses
had shown interest in my script.
All of a sudden, I was sitting in
meetings with different publishers
and talking about my book and Leona.
And I -- I could choose
who I wanted to work with.
And the best thing about
this was that I understood
that I had written something that
wasn't only interesting for me,
that also interested other people.
They said that my script
was something different
from the ordinary crime
stories that they receive.
I mean, they got -- they get
thousands of scripts every year.
It was different they said
and was something fresh
and something controversial as well.
The book became number one in
Sweden and it's now release
in 13 countries, and
the film rights are sold
to a production company
in Los Angeles.
And I have now quit my day job.
I'm no longer working at
the police department.
I'm now a fulltime author.
And once -- once I quit my
job, I thought, "Why do I have
to stay here in Stockholm?
It's raining during the winter."
So, I can write from anywhere.
So now I live permanently in Malta.
And I also have an
apartment in Barcelona.
So you understand my writing
has changed my life completely.
I will tell you about Leona.
She works at the same
place as I did.
She's a woman, a mother, a police
officer that doesn't behave
in a way that's expected of her.
She's different.
She's an antihero.
And you will not be able to
predict what she's going to do.
In my books about her, there's
a lot of twists and surprises
that might shock you, make
you angry, amazed, excited
or maybe everything
at the same time.
From an early age, Leona
knew she was different.
Her parents didn't treat her well
because they thought she behaved
in a way that little
girls shouldn't behave.
And they kept her away from
the rest of the family.
In order to survive her childhood,
Leona discovered that she had
to act normal, behave
like everyone else.
She became an expert in observing
and imitating what other people did,
and she behaved just like them.
She's got some troubles
with her emotional like
and that makes her
act in a cold way.
Throughout her life, she
struggled to be the perfect mother
to her two children, the
perfect wife to her husband
and the perfect police
detective at work.
But one day, she can't
do it anymore.
When she's around 30/35 and
she's got the perfect life,
she starts to question it.
Is this it?
Is this my life now?
She feels trapped in the
daily routines that her --
that has become her life.
She can't pretend anymore and
she decides to break free.
And from then on, she
lives by her own rules.
And that takes her on a
really dangerous path,
dangerous for herself and
the people around her.
On top of this, she is assigned
to investigate some
very unusual crimes.
This first book in the series
starts off with a bank robbery,
but I want -- I've always wanted
to write about a bank robbery,
but I didn't want to describe it in
a way that -- that's described --
usually described in -- in TV series
or literature where there's a lot
of young men running into
a bank with drawn weapons
and screaming and shooting
everywhere.
No, I didn't want that.
I wanted the bank robber
to be a vulnerable person.
That's when I saw a
little girl in front of me.
That image of a little girl walking
into a bank was really
strong in my head.
So that became the
first scene of the book.
So there's a 7-year-old girl,
walks into a bank in broad daylight
in the middle of Stockholm and
managed to get away with millions.
And that's the first case
that Leona has to investigate.
I'm going to read a few lines in
Swedish just so you get a feeling
of the language, the
original language.
And then I will read a
short part in English.
And after that, I'll be glad
to answer some questions:
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
"No one hadn't noticed her yet.
Slowly and silently, she crept along
the narrow entrance mat towards the
middle of the bank.
Her steps were determined,
her gaze, glassy.
She's no -- She no longer
felt the sores and dried blood
on her naked, slender body.
Only her heart distracted her.
She could hear every beat.
One-two-three-four-five-six.
The beats were too fast
and uneven to count.
She had the teddy bear against
her chest as hard as she could.
The pounding felt softer then.
The fluorescent were
harsh and bright compared
to the subdued bluish-gray
light outside.
She squinted, just a few
more steps, right-left-right.
She stopped in the middle of the
lobby without moving her head.
She looked around in the room,
taking in the high counters,
the computers, the people in suits.
She stood still for a brief moment
before she slowly and quietly bent
down to set the tape
recorder on the marble floor.
She lightly pressed the play
button and straightened up.
A gruff, male voice
echoed through the bank.
My name is Olivia and
I'm 7-years-old.
Now listen carefully and
do exactly as I say."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Yes, so if you have any
questions, I'll be glad to answer.
Yes? Do we have a microphone?
>> Yes, I've just started your book.
I'm about halfway through Leona,
and I've enjoyed it so far.
I think the writing is wonderful.
It's suspenseful, but I'm finding
as it goes on and the twist
that it takes, I don't
like Leona very much.
And I'm debating whether
I should just put it down
or I should finish the book.
She's -- she's not a likable
character as the book goes on.
Does that change?
And -- and obviously you've
written several others,
so she does continue, but why --
why is her character changed from
a likable person in the beginning
and as it progresses, I'm
more uncomfortable with it.
And why did you do it that way?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Okay, well thank
you for reading as far as you read.
And -- Yeah, that's actually the
thing about my book and my series
that Leona is a very special
character, and like I said,
she doesn't behave the way
that's expected of her.
And she wants to change
her life in --
so badly, she feels like
she doesn't have a choice.
She has to do something,
and she does it in a way --
It's difficult to -- to talk
about because I don't want
to spoil the reading for you, but --
So I think you're asking
if she's going to be nicer?
Yes, okay.
How can I -- I can't -- I
can't tell you that because
that would spoil everything
but -- but Leona is a person.
And I think also because
she's a woman because you --
you read about men doing
all kinds of bad things.
But when it comes to a woman,
there seems to be different rules.
So I would like to -- Yeah, I would
like to let you think about what --
what would you have thought about
the character if she had been a man?
Would you react the same way?
I would like the readers to
think about that when they read.
So, yeah? Yes, another question?
>> Yes, I'm curious about
the process of translation.
Did you translate your own book?
And if not, did you have any control
over the result of the translation?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah.
Thank you for the question.
The -- the first English
translation was actually
for the Australian market.
So it was first --
first the translated
to English and for Australia.
And then when it was going to be --
going to be released here
in the states, there was --
there was another -- We went
through the -- the whole --
the whole script again -- the whole
book again and made some changes
for the American -- American market.
And yes, I was involved with that,
but I don't translate my own books.
I -- I speak English but I wouldn't
be able to write in -- in --
in English language, so yeah?
Yes?
>> Good morning.
I started downstairs in
the Children's section
for the author of Wonder.
That makes me think,
what were your --
What did you read when
you were young?
And I mean like ten
and up -- ten and up.
Ten --
>> Jenny Rogneby: What I
wanted -- Sorry, I didn't --
>> The books that you were
exposed to that you liked
when you were your
early teens that --
>> Jenny Rogneby: I mean this --
When I was child it was a lot of
Swedish authors, Pippi Longstocking.
She's a strong female
character, so that was --
I think that was influential
for me, so --
But Astrid Lindgren who
wrote Pippi Longstocking --
She wrote so many other great
stories that me and, yeah,
all Swedish child --
children are reading.
Yeah.
Yes?
>> So to be honest, I was not
aware of your book or you,
but now I'm very interested.
And I just googled you, and it's not
-- This book is not out in audible.
Is it coming out in audible?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Oh it's not.
Now -- I'll -- I'll have to talk
to my American publisher to --
to talk about -- to
-- to answer that.
I'm not sure.
I hope so, maybe.
I don't know how things
are done here.
If it goes well, maybe
they do an audio, but --
>> How long has it been out here?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Since first of
-- first of August here, yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Hi.
>> -- So, first off, I have
Asperger's Syndrome and I'm used
to sort of reading
fictional characters in ways
that now I can kind of tell are
being described around the edges
as having symptoms thereof.
Obviously, the big ones,
especially in terms
of Swedish fiction is Elizabeth from
The Girl With the Dragon Tattoo,
but was that ever your
intent with Leona?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah,
that's a good question.
I -- I -- She has -- she has some
-- some difficulties, and I --
I haven't given her a diagnosis
in the book, so that -- that --
I didn't want to do that,
so maybe it comes later on.
But she definitely
have some difficulties
with her emotional life.
You can -- you can see that
clearly when you read the books,
and that also makes her -- her
react in the way she -- she does.
So, if it was on purpose,
yes it was.
>> Thank you.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah.
>> Good morning.
I -- I just wanted to let
you know I'm a big reader
of female conscious --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Sorry, I can't --
>> -- female conscious [phonetic],
female mysteries and stuff.
And I read [inaudible].
I read Sue Grafton.
I read [inaudible].
I read a lot of female writers.
And how would you liken your
character to the writers
that I've mentioned as far as
personality and stuff like that?
[Inaudible] comedy.
Can you understand me?
>> Jenny Rogneby: I have
a little difficulty --
>> Okay, okay, let me
be more clear, okay?
As I was saying, I love
reading mystery books, okay.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Okay.
>> And most of my characters
that are female --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yes.
>> -- mystery.
And I've never read your book
before and I was just interested
on how you liken your
character to Stephanie Plum
and Janna Vanovich [Assumed
Spelling] books or Sue Grafton
and all those other mystery writers?
Is she a comedian or is she --
I -- I know she has a dark past,
but what kind of character
would you define her as being?
You know what I mean?
>> Jenny Rogneby: It -- How
-- how -- how Leona is --
how I would define her you mean?
>> Well what I'm saying is --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Compared
to -- to other --
>> She -- she has a dark
past, but is she a comedian?
Is she -- You know -- you
understand what I'm saying?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah, that
was a difficult question
to -- to compare her.
I mean she's -- I would have
to say she is quite unique.
>> Okay.
>> Jenny Rogneby: It's difficult
to compare it to other --
to other because -- I mean I
wanted to challenge the norms
when I was writing the
character of Leona --
>> Okay.
>> Jenny Rogneby: -- and so, she
is -- she is different from --
from any other character,
so it's difficult
for me to compare with others.
>> I don't mean to compare,
but I was just interested based
on the fact that I love
reading mystery books.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's difficult.
That was a tough question
you've given me here.
>> Okay.
>> Jenny Rogneby: I'll have
to think about that one.
>> I'm very disappointed to learn
that you don't have
an audio version.
I -- I hope you'll urge your
publisher to have an audio version.
I lost more than 50 pounds since I
discovered audio versions of books.
>> Jenny Rogneby: That's
good, that's great.
>> And that's all I listen
to now and I really would
like to listen to your book
>> Jenny Rogneby: Okay, I will
pass that onto my publisher.
Thank you for that.
Yeah. Great.
Yes?
>> I was wondering based on
your seven plus years of working
for the Stockholm Police, how --
how much your experience
with particular cut kinds
of crimes informs the crimes or the
other thoughts within your books?
>> Jenny Rogneby: I
think I used a lot --
a lot of my knowledge and my own
-- I mean both from my education
and from my experience as an
investigator to the -- to my books.
I mean, I'm not writing
about a certain --
certain investigation or a
certain case that I've --
I've investigated myself, but I
mean the everyday life at the --
at the police station, the -- some
of the characters I could find in --
in I mean my own work
and colleagues.
So -- And I mean of course,
I mean, I've been sitting
in those interrogations, and the
questioning rooms and everything
and I've -- I've done
all the work myself,
so it of course makes it easier
for me to write about it.
So, yeah, I probably wouldn't
have written this kind of story
if I didn't have that background
in working within the police force.
Yes?
>> Can you talk about your personal
discipline and your risk taking
to take a year off of work and
go to Malta and write a book?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Sorry,
one more time.
I can't hear you.
>> Just can you talk
about the motivation
for you take a year off --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yes
>> -- I mean, a level of risk taking
and there's a level of discipline
to write a book within a year.
Can you talk about that process?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, since I didn't work at
the same time as I was writing,
I could -- I had power on my own
time, and yes, you need a lot
of discipline to -- to -- to write
and to get the whole book done,
because maybe in the beginning
you have a lot of ideas.
You just want to -- to write it --
write it down, but
you need structure.
It's very -- I mean writing a --
a crime fiction story, you need --
you need to really -- I mean the
-- You need to have a schedule
and you -- I usually
write a synopsis so I --
so I write, like, three
or four pages with the --
with the whole story before I
start to write the actual book.
So, that's how I do it.
And I write of course every day,
not at the same timeframe every day.
Sometimes I work in the
morning, most of the time
in the evening and nighttime.
I'm an evening/night person.
I don't get much done in
the morning, but yeah.
So -- I -- Just some days
are easier of course.
Some days, it's really hard.
I mean I can sit a few
hours and just get two
or three lines on the paper.
But on other -- other days, I
could write many pages, so, yeah.
Yes?
>> Yes. Congratulations
on your success.
We're so happy that you're here.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Thank you.
>> What has been your
greatest surprise or joy
in the process of publishing?
And what has been the
-- one of the challenges
and the challenges
that you experienced?
>> Jenny Rogneby: The
surprises -- I never --
The biggest surprise is that
it's gone really this well.
I mean, I couldn't
imagine standing here
or I mean releasing a
book in so many countries.
When I first started, I just --
My goal was to just
finish the first book.
I didn't have -- I mean I
didn't know whether it's going
to be published or not.
And now I -- I released
three books in Sweden.
So -- so, yeah, and film rights
-- It was -- That's the --
that's the biggest surprise I
think that everything went so well.
>> Good morgon.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Good morgon.
>> Being Swedish, I wonder how much
of the Swedish character
you have put in Leona.
It's like I always get questions
about how much coffee we
drink, you know, in the books.
>> Jenny Rogneby: How much
-- Sorry, one more time.
>> How much of a Swedish
character, like,
you know we are supposedly
reserved and, you know,
there's a lot of things that
Swedes are thought to be --
Have you used any of those
characters in creating Leona?
>> Jenny Rogneby: I mean --
I mean, she's very difficult
Swedish I think, Leona.
I mean -- I mean except
for the fact that I mean
that she wants another life, a
lot of people in Sweden is like --
They -- they say to me now when
I moved outside of Sweden like,
yeah, oh, that's really nice.
So you took, you know, you
took the chance and you --
you moved outside to a
sunny island and writing.
But most people in Sweden,
they are really struggling hard
and some people want
to do that, but --
And I think a lot of people don't
understand that they can as well.
They can follow their dreams.
So in that sense, Leona
is a little bit different
because she takes actions as well.
>> Did you follow up about the
challenges and disappoints?
That was the second question.
>> Jenny Rogneby: Oh
yeah, yeah, sorry.
The challenges, oh my God, there are
so many challenges
in writing a book.
The -- the biggest challenge -- It's
so much more work than I thought.
I mean, maybe I was a little bit
naive and I -- I knew it was a --
a lot of work, but how much
work I didn't know that.
So that's -- that's the
challenge I think to --
to be able to finish a
story and then the storyline
and describe the dialogue.
And there's so many parts in writing
that you don't know is difficult
before you actually start.
So maybe it was good that I
didn't know that before, yeah.
Okay, may -- We have,
okay one more question.
>> My question is about --
-- Scandinavian detective --
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yes.
>> -- fiction in general?
It seems -- at least my knowledge
may be wrong, but my impression is
that crime rate in
Scandinavia is relatively low
or murder rate is relatively low,
and I -- I -- and yet, you know,
detective fiction or --
is very successful and there's
so many authors that are
at least successful here
and wondering why is that?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yeah,
yeah, that's a good question.
>> And secondly, I'm wondering
if any of these other authors
that we're aware from Sweden
and other Scandinavian countries
inspired you in any way?
>> Jenny Rogneby: Yes,
very good question.
I get that question a lot when
I'm outside of Sweden because --
And the people are saying, are
there a lot of murderers walking
around in the streets in Sweden?
I think -- I mean we
had a long tradition
of crime fiction in Sweden.
And in a way, I think that --
I mean Sweden is a quiet,
calm and safe society.
And I think that in those
kind of places, you -- you --
you want some excitement
in some way, yeah.
So -- Because I mean in --
in countries that where --
where there's a lot of
problems, I mean war,
crime stories isn't that big.
I mean of course.
So, I think when you're
sitting there in your, you know,
your safe life, you want to read
about something else that's
something, and you know --
And also the -- the mystery I think.
All of us want to read
something that --
that, you know, that you can
try -- you -- you know, you --
you're trying to solve a
problem or solve a mystery.
So -- But yeah, you're right.
That's a good point actually, yeah.
Okay, I think we're done.
Thank you so much for all
the questions and thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.